es ist eine unglaublich tolle plattform
aber mittlerweile hier nutzt das jeder
um sich bild darzustellen sich auch
darzustellen wie man tatsächlich auch
nicht ist jedes model jeder ist vor
jeder schön jeder ist keine ahnung was
also ich meine das ist viele vergessen
auch morgen ist ein job und wo man muss
abliefern können und und kam mit
photoshop hin oder her ich habe auch mal
irgendwie nicht wirklich oder sowie
photoshop das ist auch klar dass kim ich
auch ehrlich zu aber dann auch
zusätzlich kommt noch dazu dass man dann
auch mittlerweile auch instagram so
krass die leute sage ich jetzt mal
hintergeht seine follower schafft
hintergeht indem man dinge auch verkauft
und sonstige erst am am tag das produkt
am anderen tag das und ich merke dass
auch extrem zum beispiel meine follower
schafft wenn ich was poste über kunst
und kultur oder etwas interessant ist
auch was politisches habe ich sofort 200
dollar weniger wo ich mich dann sagen
okay wenn ich ein bild hochladen würde
wie manche andere instagram blogger
tatsächlich da da schießt das in die
höhe